so I've been thinking that I believe
human beings all Harbor kind of primal
trauma
I think the moment of birth is the first
initial the initiation the agony of
separation the first time in which we
experience fragmentation from being in a
kind of cosmic merger with the divine
being with a goddess with our mother
for all of a sudden trembling naked
before the cosmos and I think that
primal trauma I think that initial
separation leaves us all with a
intermittent PTSD I think that we carry
the scars from birth and that these
fears these traumas resurface at pivotal
periods of our lives I think a lot of
the patterns in our romantic life in
particular reflect this primal trauma
reflect this fear of abandonment I know
for in my own romantic life I tend to
idealize romantic partners I tend to
turn them into goddesses in order that
they can serve as conduits for that
divine merger for that return to the
womb with a view so to speak before that
primal trauma and so what's really
interesting is that we spend our lives
perpetually re-enacting these traumatic
experiences without ever realizing where
they stem from in order to address them
and potentially heal them it's why we
make such a failure of our romantic
undertakings and why most people lead
lives of quiet desperation I think the
fear of loneliness I think the cosmic
fear of a
is polluting our romantic lives in ways
that we don't often address and so the
question becomes that is there a
solution is there a kind of journey of
transformation our own version of the
Eat Pray Love undertaking where we learn
to become whole on our own so that
meaning somebody else becomes an
additive a supplement rather than a
feeling of a vacuum so to speak and it's
a journey I haven't quite figured out
you know meandering walks on the beach
and contemplative introspection is just
one way of trying to find an answer to
the question that drives us and I
haven't figured it out
[Music]